bonsoir à tout ce nous sommes le mardi
24 mai merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
comme chaque jour nous revenons sur
l'actualité locale avec nos invités
mais également avec les journalistes de
cette rédaction tout de suite on
commence avec les titres de cette
édition internet en très haut débit dans
tout le département c'est l'objectif du
conseil départemental ils deviennent
numériques fundica mixte créée dans le
but de relier plus de cent mille foyers
un réseau très haut débit à l'horizon
2020 a officiellement été lancée
vendredi dernier à versailles violences
contre les policiers dans les
manifestations voitures incendiées les
forces de l'ordre ont manifesté la
semaine dernière pour exprimer leur
colère et la situation tendue qui est la
leur en ce moment pour en parler ce soir
notre invité ses marines béraud
secrétaire régional syndicat alliance
police nationale les yvelines et l'euro
2016 de football approche à grands pas
pour tenter de gagner les rares et
précieux billets pour assister au match
d euros dictées sont organisées samedi
c'est najat vallaud belkacem ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui s'est mis dans
la peau d'un professeur attrape nous y
étions
et pour commencer ce journal la pénurie
d'essence qui est plus que jamais
d'actualité en france une station
service sur quatre souffre de pénurie
partielle ou totale
le département des yvelines n'y échappe
pas pourtant il ya peu de stations comme
vous le voyez actuellement sur la carte
qui sont en rupture totale des 100 sur
notre territoire mais les files
d'attentes sont toujours plus longues
autour des stations d'essence beaucoup
d'automobilistes font des provisions par
précaution plus que par nécessité
pourtant la situation devrait durer la
cgt entend continuer les blocages des
raffineries pour se faire entendre par
le gouvernement
comme l'expliqué emmanuel lépine le
secrétaire général de la branche pétrole
de la cgt écoutez le nous l'avons eu au
téléphone ce matin
alors on perd lui l'affinerie sur huit
en grève dans le pays
et puis même à d'autres secteurs qui
commence à bouger au par exemple la
pétrochimie qui aussi s'est mis en grève
reconductible haché naphtachimie et puis
aussi aggravation puisqu'il ya un type
pétrochimique à gravenchon délimiter
guide donc donc un travail ce rapport
sera pas démontrée
je vous le disais en titre le
déploiement du très haut débit pour le
grand public s'intensifie dans le
département le conseil départemental
adhésives in a officiellement lancé
yvelines numériques vendredi dernier
c'était à versailles un syndicat mixte
ouvert et créé dans le but de relier
plus de cent mille foyers un réseau très
haut débit et cela à l'horizon 2020 les
précisions de camions vers le très haut
débit pour tous d'ici 2020 c'est
l'objectif que s'est donné le conseil
départemental des yvelines
vendredi 20 mai à versailles pierre
bédier président du conseil
départemental et karl olive ont présenté
le syndicat mixte ouvert yvelines
numériques une structure publique créée
par le département qui permettra de
déployer le réseau très haut débit pour
le grand public comme l'expliquent son
vice-président alors plusieurs solutions
d'abord la possibilité d'être fibre est
très rapidement ça c'est la première la
deuxième pour des aides pour des zones
un tout petit peu plus reculée où je
dirais la les kilomètres de voirie
affaires et km2 de fibres à pouvoir
accomplir sont trop importantes
il ya une montée en débit qui est
proposée sur les 232 commune yvelinoise
seulement 104 sont gérés par les
opérateurs privés 158 communes sont donc
concernés par ce nouveau syndicat des
zones essentiellement rural cent mille
foyers attendent encore d'être équipé du
très haut débit
c'est au service public de se déployer
mais ce service public aujourd'hui il a
un coot le coot il est assuré par les
contribuables
donc c'est cet équilibre entre le
consommateur et le contribuable que
notre collectivité et cei
de mettre en oeuvre de la façon la plus
pertinente possible
le syndicat yvelines numériques et
envisage d'investir 110 millions d'euros
pour mener à bien cette opération
financée en majorité par le département
9 intercommunalités adhèrent déjà au
dispositif les territoires de versailles
grand parc et saint-quentin-en-yvelines
n'en font pas encore partie
la cgt des yvelines organisée ce
vendredi une première soirée portes
ouvertes destinée aux salariés des très
petites entreprises les responsables du
syndicat ont reçu à cette occasion des
dizaines de salariés pour les informer
sur leurs droits dont les tpe un
reportage signé mickaël millero les très
petites entreprises regroupe plus de 80
mille salariés dans le département pour
les informer sur leurs droits la cgt des
yvelines organisée ce vendredi soir à
trappes une soirée portes ouvertes sur
les tpe
au programme de la réunion des débats
sur les conditions de travail les
salaires ou encore les formations
la cgt a l'ambition d'être le syndicat
de tous les salariés dans toute leur
diversité
les salariés des très petites
entreprises donc moins de 11 salariés
sans représentants du personnel dans
l'entreprise sont très nombreux dans des
tas de secteurs différents
donc c'est bien sûr un enjeu de pouvoir
les toucher les organiser discuter avec
eux de ce qu'ils vivent au travail
comment on peut améliorer les choses
dans leur travail pour présenter leur
action le syndicat projeté un film sur
les tpe dans la salle des dizaines de
pochette d'information également été
remises à cette occasion on a mis dans
dance et pochette d'accueil
notre répertoire du département donc
avec ce qu'on fait dans les yvelines des
modèles de l'aide des coordonnées utiles
on a aussi des tracts spécifique aux tpe
ou par ou par métier et puis ça annonce
un petit peu nos dates sur le
département
au total une vingtaine de salariés à
participer à l'événement la prochaine
réunion de la cgt se tiendra le 6 juin
24 heures- jean jaurès attrape le
rendez-vous concernera les salariés du
secteur des hôtels des cafés et des
restaurants
il est temps à présent de passer à notre
entretien aujourd'hui nous recevons
marine béraud secrétaire régional
syndicat alliance police nationale
bonsoir à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors le dixième
à dernier les syndicats de policiers se
sont mobilisés et ont exprimé leur
colère dans la rue l'association est
aujourd'hui plus que tendue oui tout à
fait comme vous le disiez donc une
manifestation au nom d'alliance police
nationale a été organisée en date du 18
mai pour que nos collègues puissent eux
dénoncé la haine anti-flic et la
stigmatisation qui est fait aujourd'hui
des policiers sur le terrain
alors aujourd'hui la situation se
complique un peu plus avec cette pénurie
de carburant pour vous est-ce que tout
d'abord d'un point de vue logistique
ça n'empêche rien vous pouvez toujours à
circuler et faire votre travail
correctement tout à fait tout à fait ça
pose absolument qu'un problème les
collègues peuvent toujours pas tout y
est et puis travailler dans de bonnes
conditions
après s'il ya des complications je pense
qu'il y aura quand même des consignes de
donner à hauteur de la direction
départementale voire du préfet pour que
le nécessaire soit fait alors vous avez
également être mobilisés par exemple sur
le blocage des raffineries comme ce
matin ce qui s'est passé à fos-sur-mer
ou donc la police est arrivée pour lever
le barrage mis en place par la cgt
c'est plus de travail pour vous est-ce
que ça vous inquiète plus de travail non
ça reste quand même des missions de de
police maintenant les collègues comment
ils sont amenés et quand ils sont
mobilisés justement pour pouvoir
rétablir une situation ils font tout
simplement leur travail maintenant il
n'ya pas plus d'inquiétude comme ça
parce que c'est quand même ça reste
quand même des collègues et des
policiers qui sont qui sont
professionnels qui sont formés pour ça
et dans les stations essence est ce que
vous avez cités de l'attestation un peu
tendues avec les automobilistes qui
viennent s'approvisionner parfois on
leur refuse absolument pas d'ailleurs
j'en discutais tout à l'heure avec avec
des collègues du département absolument
pas n'y a pas eu de d'incidents de
relever au sein de certaines stations
alors je devrais revenir donc sur la
manifestation du 18 mai qu'on a vu cette
voiture incendiée ce policier blessé est
ce que ça reflète vraiment la station
des policiers en france aujourd'hui
c'est la relance à ce qu'ils vivent au
jour le jour
oui tout à fait tout à fait et
d'ailleurs c'est des images et une vidéo
qui est qui et qui est parlante qui est
criante et qui montre tout à fait la
violence qui est exercée à l'encontre de
de mes collègues dans l'heure dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions est-ce que
vous avez déjà connu une situation
un tel contexte auparavant où c'est
quand même voilà assez exceptionnel ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui je dirais que
cette violence elle a toujours existé
ç'a toujours été exercées à l'encontre
de des forces de l'ordre mais ça a pris
au fus au fur et à mesure des années ça
a pris de l'ampleur
et donc c'est de l'agressivité qui qui
est de plus en plus importante est
omniprésente alors qu'on voit par
exemple
après les attentats donc du 13 novembre
les français les français ont plébiscité
les forces de l'ordre aujourd'hui la
situation voilà les français ne sont pas
tous contre la police mais quand même on
voit qu'il y avait un sentiment un peu
de haine parfois on peut le dire mais
qu'est ce que ça vous fait été sabrée
comment vous le ressentez ça même que
vous dites vos collègues et elle en est
je pense je pense que c'est tout
simplement véhiculées par des vidéos
ponctuellement qu'on va voir qui sont
diffusées sur youtube où on va prendre
des situations bien particulières dans
laquelle les collègues ce tout se trouve
et il ya une interprétation d'un
comportement d'un geste sans compter les
tenants et les aboutissants d'une
situation montre pas une situation ce
qui s'est passé avant et ce qui va se
passer après donc c'est sûr que ça donne
une mauvaise image de de mes collègues
alors justement on voit que dans les
manifestations contre justement à
l'article 49-3 le projet le travail
c'est quand même très violent on dit que
les casseurs sont des casseurs
professionnels des gens qu'on
retrouverait dès qu'ils sont sur les
indices sur les barrages de sivens est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça ou est
ce que finalement peut-être que ce sont
tous les français qui excédés se livrent
à des actes de violence non non je pense
pas que ce soit tous les français
effectivement je pense que yahia il ya
un groupe de deux personnes rebelles qui
veulent en découdre tout simplement avec
avec la police qui se mélangent des
manifestations qui peuvent être
pacifique et qui vont en profiter de ce
fait de pouvoir dégradé de descendre des
vitres au niveau des commerçants
mais maintenant c'est une attitude qui
est pas propre à toute la population
quand on veut que le policier dont katia
était vu sa voiture safer incendie qui a
été blessée a été décoré par le
gouvernement par françois hollande
vous en pensez quoi vous dites alors
voilà ce police est là il a été décoré
mais finalement nous on ne nous aide pas
nous entend pas non non je pense que
qu'il soit décoré et qui soit
qu'il y ait une reconnaissance je dirais
le fait notamment de le nommer gardiens
de la paix et qu'ils soient décorés
c'est tout à fait normal parce que il ya
quand même un sentiment de la part de
mes collègues ne pas avoir si vous
voulez de reconnaissance déjà au niveau
de la hiérarchie ponctuellement au
niveau de la population donc ça reste
quand même significatif et on prend en
considération le côté dangereux de la
profession qu'on exerce au quotidien
parce que derrière tout ça il ya quand
même il ya quand même un danger de leur
vie pour les hommes et les femmes qui
composent de la police nationale
aujourd'hui
après les attentats également il ya une
grosse campagne de communication pour
recruter justement des policiers faire
entrer les jo dans la police nationale
après l'attentât ya beaucoup de gens qui
se sont dirigés vers ceux qui ont voulu
entrer dans la police nationale est-ce
que après qu'on voit des événements
comme ça les policiers se faire agresser
où il ya moins de personnes qui vont
vouloir rail à l'aise que vous allez
tant de manques d'effectifs
non absolument peur on a toujours on a
toujours du monde qui va candidater pour
devenir effectivement policiers parce
que mon épouse une profession qui est
quand même bien particulière et
aujourd'hui c'est une profession qui est
quand même quand même pas mal médiatisé
donc je pense que les personnes qui est
candidate et qui sont recrutés mais
rentre en tout état de cause et vous
avez des collègues qui justement on en
marre de ces situations ont ras-le-bol
et peut-être démissionner non non
justement ça peut être ça peut être
contradictoire mais mes collègues du
fait qu'il y ait eu les attentats du
fait qu'il y ait eu la mise en place de
l'état d'urgence reste quand même
reste quand même motivé mobilisés pour
pouvoir protéger la population
malgré quand même une une grande fatigue
et à l'épuisement parce qu'on a eu des
restrictions notamment en termes de
congé et donc il ya une récupération
physiologique qui peuvent êtres qui peut
être mis en péril
alors justement parle des bavures
policières dans les manifestations est
ce que pour vous voilà c'est des cas
isolés mais ça arrive c'est dû à l'état
d'urgence et que les policiers sur
justement trop mobilisés ne peuvent pas
prendre de congés et cela amène à faire
des erreurs
non non il peut y avoir effectivement
des cas isolés
pour autant il faut savoir que dans la
police nationale il ya quand même des il
ya quand même des dés
comment dire d d d d d instances qui
sont là aussi pour statuer pour pouvoir
effectivement prendre des décisions de
sanctions maintenant si les collègues
interviennent de telle ou telle façon
ils interviennent quand même de manière
professionnelle ils sont formés pour ça
c'est une police qui est républicaine
ils sont pas là pour prôner la violence
ils vont tout simplement essayé de
cadrer une situation de cadres et des
personnes qui vont être récalcitrante
pour ramener l'ordre public
mais on voit pas de policiers passés
dans à des actes de violence
l'état d'urgence comme ça pousse un
petit peu les forces de l'ordre à bout
il ya personne ya des personnes qui
veulent ma peau ne va pas depuis très
longtemps sa came as initiation assez
tendue pour vous ça peut être tendu
effectivement parce que comme je vous
disais il ya une récupération
physiologique qui est moindre mais
pour autant en termes en termes de
d'état d'esprit mes collègues restent
quand même mobilisé pour faire leur
travail quand même au mieux après c'est
sûr que alliance police nationale on
tire quand même la sonnette d'alarmé
parce que effectivement il ya des
recrutements qui se font néanmoins
sceptique
il n'y a pas assez d'effectifs doudou le
recrutement le recrutement qui est en
train de qui est en train de se faire
justement avec l'état d'urgence la
mobilisation qui a eu lieu digne est dit
le 18 mai vous avez eu un échange avec
le gouvernement qu'elles sont voilà les
descentes cloche que vous avez alors il
ya eu un échange au niveau donc de notre
bureau national il ya eu un échange
effectivement avec le gouvernement
alliance police nationale on a demandé
notamment au ministre de l'intérieur de
pouvoir déposer plainte mais contre ces
comportements qui nous semblent indigne
qui nous semble dangereux et qui aidé
des peines exemplaires à l'encontre de
ceux qui commettent ces délits sur la
voie publique
si vous allez continuer à manifester y
aura d'autres mobilisations si
nécessaire oui si nécessaire oui tant
qu'on n'aura pas un positionnement du
gouvernement pour avoir des peines
exemplaires dans les mois à venir dans
les semaines à venir
vous pouvez déjà en parler dire qu'une
date peut-être non non absolument pas de
date et on va s'y préparer au fur et à
mesure si c'est nécessaire mais pour
l'instant rien merci à beaucoup marine
verreaux d'être venus sont accusés
d'avoir accepté de répondre à nos
questions autre sujet maintenant
wilfried est riche et bien de nous
rejoindre pour parler politique
il est question une nouvelle fois de la
primaire en vue des présidentielles la
primaire de la droite et du centre
bien sûr on soir offrir un bon soir
florane la primaire de la droite et du
centre évidemment un quart pour la
gauche il faudra attendre le 18 juin le
ps va décider ou non à cette date de
renouveler l expérience comme en 2012 la
primaire de la droite donc une élection
ouverte à tous qui a en quelque sorte
vampirisé la présidentielle en premier
tour avant le premier tour près de 23%
des français se disent prêts à y
participer selon une enquête réalisée
elle au tout début du mois par le
parisien et bfm tv pour certains
analystes même celui qui s'imposera
alors de ce scrutin de cette primaire en
novembre sera sans doute le prochain
président est aujourd'hui toujours en
tête dans les sondages c'est alain juppé
alain juppé qui devançait nicolas
sarkozy même si ce dernier n'est pas
encore candidat officiellement viennent
ensuite bruno le maire françois fillon
ou encore nathalie kosciusko morizet les
candidats multiplient les déplacements
depuis plusieurs semaines ils occupent
leur terrain leur comité de soutien
prennent forme la semaine dernière celui
d'alain juppé à d'ailleurs fait venir et
christine albanel s'était à versailles
christine albanel
et c'est cet ancien ministre de nicolas
sarkozy à la longtemps rédiger les
discours aussi de jacques chirac avant
d'occuper le poste de présidente de
l'établissement public du château de
versailles de 2003 à 2007 pour ensuite
aller s'installer à la culture et à la
communication jusqu'en 2009 alors
pourquoi cette implication aujourd'hui
aux côtés d'alain juppé à derna juppé on
écoute sa réponse au micro de fanny
bourdillon alain juppé n'a pas fait un
choix de payet n'a pas fait un choix de
faux semblants il veut dire très
précisément ce qu'il fera c'est très
simple il dit je ferai un mandat je vais
venir pendant cinq ans je vais faire le
job et je vais tout donner
avec mon expérience avec ce que je suis
avec mon âge aussi que j'assume
totalement
et puis voilà et je ferai ce que j'ai
dit mais j'ai aussi passé 20 ans de ma
vie avec jacques chirac
il y a une famille quand même
chiraquienne avec un certain angle de
vision des choses de valeur une façon de
de prendre
bordel la vie politique est pour moi je
fais c'est quelqu'un qui fait partie de
famille alors christine albanel qui dans
le même temps ne mâche pas ses mots
envers nicolas sarkozy
elle considère que l'ancien président
était trop dans la communication il
avait je cite plus une stratégie de
communication que d'action c'est
l'ancien ministre qui le dit il faut
dire que les rapports entre les deux
n'ont pas toujours été au beau fixe
lorsque nicolas sarkozy a par exemple
annoncé en 2008 la suppression de la
publicité sur france télévisions
christine albanel était donc sa ministre
de la culture et elle n'était même pas
au courant de la sarkozie a été beaucoup
dans la communication et je le sais
parce que je ne supportais bras comme
d'ailleurs de loin dont des noces et de
la communication je pense qu'alain juppé
ne pas en dehors des communications bien
sûr il ya des règles aujourd'hui de nos
sociétés politiques modernes bien
entendu mais c'est vrai que pour lui la
réflexion de la sincérité de
l'engagement et ensuite l'action prime
un effet nettement sur la communication
c'est vrai qu effectivement elle ne
mâche pas ses mots que pense de ces
propos nicolas sarkozy
on ne sait pas trop forcément ils
évitent le sujet une chose est sûre en
tout cas pour le nicolas sarkozy pour
lui le chemin est encore long pour
convaincre de sa légitimité sur cette
nouvelle candidature un dernier chiffre
j'aime bien les chiffres dans cette
chronique politique 72% 72% à des
français qui ne souhaite pas que le
patron des républicains se présentant
dès 2017 c'est libération qui l'a publié
en début de semaine les chiffres cette
semaine ce sera tout eh bien nous
passons maintenant orthographe et foot
une fois n'est pas coutume le 10 juin
prochain petit blues vous savez en
coffret de nuit émission spéciale
d'ailleurs prévue le 10 juin prochain
débute en france l'euro 2016 à cette
occasion la direction régionale de la
jeunesse des sports et de la cohésion
sociale organise des euros dicter une
épreuve qui invitait les participants à
tester leurs hôtes leur orthographe afin
de gagner des matchs les précieux
billets pour assister à la compétition
samedi une de ses dictées à lui attrape
en présence de najat vallaud belkacem la
ministre de l'éducation nationale
mélanie poker étaient présentes regardez
ils étaient près de 300 à tenter le défi
c'est trappistes participer à l'euro
dictée et n'ont pas tous le même but
si la branche maladie
cela c'est gagner les 25 faire tester
mes capacités en orthographe
ça me permettre de dessiner mon niveau
parce que maintenant comme je disais aux
collègues avec les correcteurs
automatiques au travail on fait plus
trop attention à l'orthographe
et on se laisse aller sa dictée sur les
douze ont déjà eu lieu en ile de france
elles sont à l'initiative de la
direction régionale de la jeunesse des
sports et de la cohésion sociale
vivez cette sortir la dictée de l'école
et de montrer qu autour d'une dictée on
peut faire un moment festif et tous se
retrouver quel que soit notre génération
où notre milieu social le système
d'évaluation c'est plutôt ceux qui font
le moins de fautes de manière à ce qu'on
n'ait pas l'impression qu'il y ait une
sanction mais plutôt comme challenge se
dire je vais être le meilleur choix est
celui qui fait le moins de fautes à
trappes
ils se sont confrontés à un texte de
victor hugo 93 lui est dicté par la
ministre de l'éducation utiliser cette
opportunité pour finalement faire
revenir quand même les élèves les jeunes
leurs parents à l'essentiel c'est à dire
la bonne maîtrise de la langue française
et le bonheur que c'est que en effet de
maîtriser ce qu'on écrit ce qu'on
comprend ce qu'on écoute
dix personnes sont repartis avec deux
places pour des matches de l'euro une
finale aura lieu le 10 juin avec
d'autres cadeaux à gagner
et vous le savez peut-être peut-être pas
notre cas l'euro sera pleinement dans
les yvelines il ya trois équipes qui
seront installés dans notre département
les bleus forcément à clairefontaine les
russes il est là russe part de la russie
pardon sera à croissy sur seine et les
irlandais ont leur camp d'entraînement à
versailles la rédaction propose
d'ailleurs une émission spéciale ce sera
le 8 juin sur l'euro 2016 et sur la
question de football bien sûr mais aussi
des retombées économiques de l'euro sur
notre département
prenons la direction des lans couvre à
présent la ville vient de signer une
convention de labellisation unicef en
présence de la présidente du comité
yvelinoise de désorganisation des
nations unies elancourt dorénavant
dorénavant ville amie des enfants un
signe de reconnaissance pour les actions
menées en matière de pédagogie numérique
et d'éducation à la citoyenneté ou
encore d'accueil de la petite enfance
exemples d'initiatives salué la
plateforme destinée aux élèves du
et à la terminale de la commune baptisée
elancourt en ligne.fr depuis 2012 40 et
4000 cours en vidéo ou encore cent mille
exercices interactifs sont proposés des
devoirs de vacances sont aussi
disponibles il est également possible de
réviser le bac avec ce site internet et
la nuit des musées c'était ce samedi 21
mai en france mais aussi dans toute
l'europe une opération à l'échelle
européenne a été organisée par le
ministère de la culture et de la
communication près d'une centaine de
personnes se sont rendues au musée de la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines qui
participait comme chaque année une
soirée mêlant les arts vivants les
collections tout en abordant le mode de
vie contemporain les installations
artistiques comme celle de benoît et
baux sont venus compléter cette
installation ce duo d'artistes franco
chinois valises une collection de
portraits inédits des habitants de saint
quentin en yvelines et les visiteurs ont
même pu les rencontrer écouter la
présence des artistes
geek est un gros plus évidemment de
pouvoir les rencontrer et échanger avec
eux participer à leurs oeuvres mais
aussi de rencontrer toute l'équipe du
musée qui est là pour échanger autour du
futur projette on peut discuter on peut
échanger et vraiment c'est une soirée
qui est fait pour être convivial pour
être un moment d'échangés de rencontres
qui est moins le cas d'habitude où
évidemment dans nos activités
quotidiennes on n'est pas toujours là
pour répondre aux questions et pour
terminer ce journal la suite de notre
série consacrée au centre national du
cinéma alors vous avez pu voir hier
l'étendue du patrimoine
cinématographique et préservé sur le
site du cmc de bois d'arcy
nous vous proposons ce soir un reportage
sur le service d'inventaire et
logistique dans ce lieu chaque pellicule
déposés et inventoriées par ces
professionnels qui vérifient l'identité
de chaque produit produits afin de
l'inscrire dans la base de données du
patrimoine williams l aiguille mesquer
quand le film arrive le déposant
dwan doit nous donner nous remet un
bordereau de remise de films qu'il a
rempli lui-même à savoir qu'il a vanté
dans petit du film le réalisateur
l'année de réalisation
le numéro de visa le nombre de boîtes et
la nature de l'élément lorsqu'un film
est déposée au cnc c'est entre les mains
d'olivier de ses collègues qu'il arrive
en premier leur service inventaire et
logistique
c'est eux qui vont vérifier le contenu
du produit et s'assurer de sa conformité
me sens plus spécialement chargé de
prendre en charge tous les nouveaux
dépôts ont leur seront ici ou nous
invente aurions le film à savoir que
nous déroulons le film nous regardons le
générique nous remplissons et malgré une
grille alimentaire les films sont
ensuite inscrits dans la base de données
du cnc est renvoyé vers un espace de
stockage précis son appel nous les bois
d'origine
c'est quand le déposant arriver c'est de
voir que la mais non les champs
systématiquement on tire une étiquette
j'ai quelques décades code-barres on
retrouve toutes les informations là dont
calibre de coaltar ceux stockés en
fonction de la nature des éléments c'est
à dire que toutes les copies vivre dans
une salle des négatifs images dans une
autre salle etc etc
ceci pour éviter justement des cas d
accident très guillemets à savoir ne
s'est pas mal tremblante et c'est le
service ne travaille pas seulement sur
les nouvelles arrivées mais aussi sur
les rétrospectives des archives dans les
années soixante dix les laboratoires ont
confié de nombreux films au cnc qui
n'ont pas pu être inventoriés à l'époque
olivier doit parfois retrouver l'origine
du film en identifiant les acteurs ou
les décors un véritable travail
d'investigation dans notre base il ya
juste un titre ne sais pas ce qu'il ya
derrière
on ne sait pas si c'est par exemple un
film de fiction un film de non fiction
c'est une copie et c'est donc on demande
à sortir les boîtes au regarde ce qu'il
ya dedans et parfois on tombe sur des
trésors ou parfois là le film colle la
boîte ne correspond pas à l'élément qui
est acquis at indiqué donc on rétablit
tout ça et c'est pour la suite direction
le service analyse et gestion
muriel s'occupe des documentaires c'est
elle qui indexe les archives notre
charge à nous en fait c'est de
constituer un catalogue accessible par
les internautes par les différents
publics
qui sont concernés par nos films pour
qu'ils puissent ensuite nous demander à
consulter les fines donc ce sont aussi
bien des films de fiction que des films
documentaires
on a des films institutionnels ont
défini scientifique des films de
propagande des films de toutes les
époques
puisque les archives sont des films des
débuts du cinéma jusqu'à aujourd'hui
donc comme vous le voyez c'est très
varié et on ne peut pas s'y retrouver si
on fait pas un catalogage ici les
archives du cnc ne font pas seulement
office d'une grande médiathèque scellé
mais aussi d'un outil de travail pour
les professionnels et demain prochaine
épisode de notre série consacrée au cnc
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
je remercie de nous avoir suivis tout de
suite vous retrouver nicolas a tiré le
vide pour le 7-8 société thème du débat
le tabac et surtout l'arrivée des
paquets neutres moi je vous retrouve
demain pour une nouvelle édition du
journal je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée